several states that are moving forward
with the controversial plans to begin
reopening but we start with President
Trump's announcement that he plans to
temporarily suspend immigration into the
US and the urgent questions about his
proposal he tweeted this news last night
citing the invisible enemy of the
coronavirus and the need to protect jobs
Anthony at this point the vast majority
of US cases are not coming from outside
the country the u.s. already has by far
the most reported cases in the world
more than 700 87,000 and the most deaths
more than 42,000 nearly all immigration
had already been suspended weecha jiang
is at the White House
Ouisa what do we know a good morning
Anthony president Trump tweeted this
surprise announcement without any
context or further explanation leaving
the public guessing overnight about how
it could play out and the White House is
not providing any further explanation
but CBS News has learned that the
administration has been working on
executive action for several weeks
sources say it won't be a blanket ban
and will have some exceptions and
nuances all designed to avoid nationwide
injunctions in the court system which of
course plagued this administration's
travel bans early in the president's
term now travel and immigration have
already been restricted due to the
corona virus our March 20th the
administration effectively halted new
visa applications and president Trump
has repeatedly praised his decision to
ban travel from China and Europe and
both the northern and southern border
have been closed to all non-essential
travel several big questions are still
looming this morning like how is this
going to impact green card holders how
long is the ban going to last and
whether the president even has the
constitutional authority to carry it out
we should switching gears of the economy
it does appear that Congress is getting
closer to providing additional aid to
small businesses after the 350 billion
dollar paycheck protection program ran
out of money what can you tell us on
that front so lawmakers from both sides
in the White House have been arguing for
days over how much more money to add in
and how to spend it
here's what the final bill will likely
look like about 310 billion dollars in
additional funds for the Paycheck
protection program 60 billion reserved
for rural and minority led businesses 75
billion for hospitals and 25 billion for
Kovan 19 testing now there was Swift
backlash over the PPP after it ran out
of money on Thursday because some larger
chain corporations were able to get
loans while smaller independent
businesses were either denied or left
waiting as the money ran out Tony yeah
but it sounds like some more help is on
the way that's good news for a lot of
people we should thank you very much